drinking is definitely super gross
not worth it will not add to your life in any way
and in fact there's a huge
huge risk that you could become addicted and have it ruin your life
so in your younger years when you're 21 22
23 just getting started
be mindful of that and be very cautious with your drinking habits
I truly did not notice when I was 21
and dear god I wish I did
the human brain is not fully developed until the mid twenties 24
and one of the last part that's forming is the part that is the decision making
it in impulse control and think about it
cause it makes complete and total sense
when you're a baby the first thing you're learning is function
how do I speak how do I walk
there's so many functions that your body is learning when you're a baby infant
like there's milestones that you're reaching
like think you're still losing teeth into like your tween years
like 10 11
you're still losing teeth
like the last part of your brain and body to develop before you are truly
truly an adult is the part that helps you make decisions
so you know hold off
maybe wait until your 30s to start making some really serious life decisions
even if that is like educational
what you wanna do with life
you're only in your 20s once
uh 30s is not old
ha ha ha it is not old
you literally have plenty of time to get it all done
there's no need to rush your life and be scared into these weird timelines
because everything is made up
everything is made up you made up
everything that is your life is just shit that you made up
you're like hmm
I wanna learn how to play guitar
so now I know how to play guitar
I wanna learn how to drive a car
so now I drive a car I wanna be on the
you know basketball team
I wanna be a cheerleader I wanna learn how to swim
everything you've done up to this point is something that like
you created and you made happen
and so yeah
don't get scared into thinking these false timelines exist
they don't you live your life how you wanna live it
because it is only your life
this one is a super duper big one
but only sleep with someone if you really
really want to sleep with them
like
don't let somebody talk you into sex
that is there's names for that
and none of them are good
and it's not gonna feel good in the moment
it's not gonna do any of the things you maybe think it is
and you know
if it's a person that you even think that's a possibility of happening
you know just don't
don't spend time in rooms alone with boys like that
that's those are not fun lessons to learn
like basically the measure should be
you only sleep with someone cause you're like
oh my god I want to rip your clothes off
and I like I will
I will never stop thinking about this if I don't
you know make that happen and then think about it
think about it if you're not feeling that way
also it is totally okay to have dirty nasty
wild disgusting sex in a safe way
you keep yourself safe you use Protection
you get tested you guard your heart
you know what I mean somebody you're doing those nasty things with
is not somebody that you're probably gonna be building a family with
and you know building a family does not need to be your top priority in life
your top priority could be
how many fucking fun experiences can I have
and that could be your life's whole entire goal and mission
it really could there are lots of people who actually live that way
you get to decide what brings meaning to life
you get to decide that
never make decisions on someone
based off of the made up version of them you created in your mind
literally never
do not allow yourself to fall in love with made up versions of people
that you made up in your own head
okay I mean that one